français invité de soir3 celui que l'on
appelle le père de ce projet georges
fillioud secrétaire d'état auprès du
premier ministre chargé des techniques
de la communication alors monsieur le
ministre avant de vous demander de lever
le voile sur ce projet j'aimerais quand
même que vous commenciez par réagir à
ces différentes déclarations de
l'opposition et puis peut être également
celle du parti communiste déclaration
dont on a le sentiment qu'elles sont
tout de même un petit peu critique à
l'égard de votre projet d'abord le voile
a été levé à l'issue du conseil des
ministres de ce matin
quant aux nos réactions je viens
d'entendre moi je trouve que franchement
monsieur baumel comme chez madelin
exagère il exagère beaucoup quand on
pense que ces deux hommes politiques
appartiennent à ce qui est aujourd'hui
l'opposition mais leurs amis ont
gouverné la france pendant vannes 3 ans
ramène trois ans ils n'ont pas ouvrir la
moindre petite porte sur la liberté de
communication ni la radio ni la
télévision ils étaient les maîtres du
service public assis sur le monopole les
pdg des entreprises nationales étaient
nommés en conseil des ministres et voilà
que maintenant ils prétendent veut
donner des leçons en disant bien c'était
bien de le faire mais il fallait pas le
faire comme ça depuis une après tout le
gouvernement ait choisi enfin soyons un
peu sérieux quant à monsieur âge s'était
exprimé au nom du parti communiste on
sème la thèse habituel du mob essaie de
dire rien au privé tout doit être resté
nord enfermés dans les structures
publiques jeu qu'on peut répondre à
cette me critique c'est que justement le
gouvernement a eu dans les décisions
qu'il a arrêté ce matin leur souci de
maintenir d'organiser pour le futur un
équilibre entre le privé et le public
comme il l'a fait rentrer le national et
le local mais en ce qui concerne l'
équilibre privé public le gouvernement a
pris une décision tout à fait
exceptionnel ce matin puisque il a
décidé d'abonder les moyens du service
public de 700 millions c'est pas une
paille ça résulte de l'abaissement qui
vient d'être décidé du taux de la tva
perçue par le fisc sur leurs vans donc
était jusqu'ici 18 6% et qui va donc
passer l'année prochaine à cette
justement avant de lever le le voile
parce que vous vous dites on en a dit
beaucoup en renseignements vous allez
nous en dire un petit peu plus autour de
cette table parlons du financement la
redevance pour toutes ces chaînes va
augmenter ou pas elle reste la même elle
a l'air devant
le budget pour 86 n'est pas encore
définitivement arrêté mais dès
maintenant je peux vous dire que la
redevance augmentera faiblement elle
augmentera disons durée taux moyen de
l'inflation l'augmentation des prix
alors à fr3 ya deux choses qui nous
intéresse particulièrement tout d'abord
cette chaîne culturelle puisqu'on va
accueillir une partie des émissions de
cette chaîne culturelle un petit peu
avant ou un petit peu après soir 3 / sur
l'antenne nationale et puis ensuite les
chaînes locales puisque elles entreront
directement en concurrence dans certains
cas avec les stations régionales alors
cette chaîne culturelle ça sera quoi ça
sera une chaîne de télévision ça sera
une entreprise privée ces 700 millions
sont tous destinés à la chaîne
culturelle comme comment ça va
fonctionner puisque est ce qu'il y aura
on va on va diffuser un opéra on va
diffuser une pièce de terre alors
naturellement je suis pas en état
aujourd'hui de nous a eu l'idée d'écrire
une grille de programmes ce que je peux
dire c'est que ce projet qui a était
étudiée par pierre desgraupes en
fonction d'une mission que je lui avais
demandé d'accomplir à partir du début de
cette année c'est un programme de haute
qualité
destinée à être diffusée sur le
satellite de télévision directe à partir
de l'automne 86 satellite aura été
lancée mais tout le monde ne sera pas
équipée 1 alors
les français et les européens c'est
qu'ils pourront de façon progressive en
antenne de réception car leur avantage
de ce système de diffusion c'est que ça
permettra de couvrir la quasi-totalité
de l'europe permettra à la france de
parler en français à l'ensemble du
continent européen avec des programmes
de bonne qualité
oui concert tout ce qui constituera
événements culturels dans l'espace
européen sinon clairement un projet
d'une très grande ambition qui permettra
à la france de s'exprimer avec son génie
sa culture ses oeuvres son patrimoine sa
créativité c'est pierre des gros qui en
sera le patron séquelles rp chargé d'une
mission d'étude nos clients un/une un
autre un honneur un organisme spécifique
sera mise en place mais c'est une
mission du service public donc dans le
cadre du service public que cette
initiative se développera et vous me
demandez comment le financement sera
assuré et bien c'est précisément par les
moyens supplémentaires à hauteur de 700
millions que me sera financé dans un
premier temps cette opération est soit
ces 700 millions seront répartis selon
les besoins de l'ensemble du service
public car il s'agit sur l'arthur a
uniquement sur la chaîne culturelle dont
vous parlez puisque mais il s'agit
là tensions profondes du gouvernement de
faire en sorte que la capacité de
création de production
audiovisuelle française se développe
parce que on imagine bien le formidable
danger devant lequel nous nous
trouverions si on multipliait les
réseaux
tiers hertziennes le câble demain le
satellite sans avoir le souci de
renforcer notre outil de production car
si cette a évoqué tout à l'heure dans un
reportage vous pouvez peut-être nous
dire quelque chose sur les chaînes
locales on sait qu'on n'a pas très bien
compris d'abord sur quel émetteurs
étaient les maîtres dans un premier
temps on a pensé excepté au moment où il
n'y a pas d'émission sur tf1 antenne 2
fr3 et puisqu'on n'a pas compris aussi
sait comment ils vont être choisis c'est
ça la grosse question alors le schéma
est relativement simple nous sommes
là sous la contrainte de données
physiques ou y at il des fréquences
disponibles pour installer un émetteur
supplémentaires compte tenu des réseaux
qui couvre déjà le territoire national
alors s'arrêter on sait que tdf a les
documents mais aujourd'hui on n'a pas pu
la voir bon alors vous avez peut-être
quelques lumières led vous dit peut-être
peut-être vous y être vous êtes vous
pris un peu trop tard mais en tout cas
je me suis assuré auprès d'edf de ce
document
d'étude travail ce n'est pas définitif
et être à la disposition
de la presse poubelle puissent l'étudier
bon choisit alors
une fois attribué les
émetteurs disponible aux deux chaînes
nationales non vous allez parler se dire
dans une les 60 plus grandes villes de
france il ya des villes dans lesquelles
il restera des fréquences disponibles
elles seront offertes à qui voudra les
exploiter ça fait l'autorité ça c'est la
haute autorité ça suppose une
modification de la loi qui interviendra
encore la session d'automne c'est
l'autorité qui étudiera les dossiers
accordera les autorisations comme elle
le fait depuis trois ans pour les radios
locales prennent la première chaîne q la
première chaîne rai local plutôt privé
pourra émettre à partir de quand elle a
les délais sont d'une part le temps pour
les promoteurs de préparer leurs
programmes et d'autre part sur le plan
technique le temps nécessaire pour tdf
d'installer les métèques avant le
printemps 80 sinon j'espère que le
plusieurs de ces initiatives pourront
démarrer dès la fin de cette année ou en
tout cas au tout début de l'année
prochaine monsieur le ministre je vous
remercie l'autre